when it comes to the financial fallout
from the coronavirus the impact has not
been held felt equally it's forced a
record-breaking number of small
businesses to close at least temporarily
and what we're looking at this morning
is how the pandemic is affecting diverse
communities economically and medically
consider this there was a 41 percent
decline in black businesses business
owners rather from February to April and
a 32 percent drop in Latino business
owners that is compared to a 17 percent
decrease in white business owners
airborne net has examined some of these
inequities aryl good morning really
striking figures what did you learn hey
that good morning Tony
you're right well what we know is that
this struggle is real of course covert
19 has impacted hundreds of millions of
Americans we've all been touched in some
way whether it's medically financially
socially or psychologically and while
we've long said this virus doesn't
discriminate the numbers do show us that
this is hitting the pocketbooks of
minorities the hardest and right now
they are struggling to stay afloat
inside one of the wealthiest countries
in the world
sobering images like these have flashed
across television strains and been
printed on newspaper pages struggling
Americans looking for food it's a
symptom of kovat 19 although it's not
one you'll find in a medical journal as
the pandemic now stretches into the
summer the economic impact of the
disease is coming into sharper focus for
many in America's work in class the work
has dried up national unemployment
figures at their highest levels since
the Great Depression and for African
Americans that number deepens to nearly
17 percent will Turner lost his popular
Atlanta area restaurant after Kovich
shuttered the state of Georgia and as
far as a federal economic injury
disaster loan Turner was denied forced
to reopen his old food truck to try and
support his family I had a friend of
mine who also owns a Pilates studio here
in Atlanta hurry I
loan was approved for $300,000 however
mine was denied you can call it classism
racism whatever you want to call it but
when the lead advisor to the president
says that there's no such thing as
systemic racism in our society and he's
leading the advisory board on economics
to the president we got a serious
problem in this country the pandemic
really does shine a light on a number of
economic disparities along racial lines
Valerie Wilson directs the economic
policy Institute's program on race
ethnicity and economy so many black
owned businesses are really lifelines
for their parts of the city their
lifelines in their parts of the city
they can hire an employ more people are
an important part of building and
strengthening the US economy as a whole
a recent survey of 500 minority-owned
businesses found only 12% received a
loan amount requested and nearly 2/3 had
yet to receive any help it's New York
City salon owner Juliet Anderson is one
of the many Americans who hasn't seen
any loan assistance from the government
her shop is in the Bronx the New York
Borough with one of the highest minority
populations in America's largest city
has been a complete full stop in terms
of income in terms of livelihood I would
say nine of the ten did not get the yes
and so they've been struggling to stay
afloat just staying afloat during the
pandemic is a problem so many Americans
are wrestling with including will turn
out just like the actual virus that
people are catching black people are
disproportionately affected by it
because we already had more pre-existing
conditions than white people did and
just like black businesses if you had a
pre-existing condition in your black
business your chances of survival were a
lot less than your white counterpart
now will Turner tells us he just got
approved for a PPP loan but
unfortunately it won't be anywhere near
enough to save his restaurant and as for
Juliet she does plan to open her
business today as New York City enters
phase two of this reopening plan that
allows Hair Salons barber shops and
other non-essential businesses to open
their doors but the key question here is
Gayle will the customers be back and for
how many business owners is it already
too late a lot of people's waiting for
the answer to that question thank you
very much
I thought Will Turner & Arrows piece
made such a good point you at least have
to acknowledge anything anything that
there is a problem and it's a that
systemic racism doesn't exist it's it's
kind of hard to even get past that if
people won't acknowledge that listen
people are hurting here this is a real
real thing you have to look and say at
least there might be a problem let's
look and see if there is ya can't just
close the door now a lot of doors are
closing it's tough